So that brings us to the end of the
topics we are going to talk about in terms of
neural nets. There's going to be some interesting stuff
for you to do in terms of the homework where
you'll be exposed to some other important concepts. But
that's, that's all we're going to lecture about for now.
So let's just remind ourselves what exactly we covered in
the neural net section. So Charles what do you remember?
>> I remember perceptrons. I remember.
>> And
perceptron was a threshold unit, a linear threshold
unit, and we could put networks of them together.
>> Yes.
>> To produce any Boolean function. What else?
Oh, we had a learning rule for perceptrons.
>> Mm-hm. Which runs in finite time for linearly separable data sets.
>> And we learned a general differentiable rule. Adding
general we learned about propagation using a gradient set.
>> And
we talked a little bit about the, about the preference
and restriction by c's of neural networks. Alright, til next time.
>> See you Michael.